your husband because you mentioned is a
director and I would think because
you're an actor he's a director does
that mean when you guys are watching
television you watch it in different
ways like you're watching it from the
acting perspective he's watching it from
the directing perspective I would say
that yeah I think so he watches you know
well
Game of Thrones which we love he watches
for the boobs I would watch it for the
boobs
he watches for the booth the best boobs
who ever cast the show he always this he
loves the scenery and then he goes up at
the boobs that's not a director's point
of view directing expertise no that's
not
oh my god yeah I really did I just broke
my head but anywho so he really just
watch for the boobs because it doesn't
take long on games have you seen that
show if I seen that show I've never
missed an episode
okay people take off their clothes for
no reason well time to go to the bank we
better have a secret meeting how about
the brothel what's going on back there
anyway yeah shameless I'm not shameless
at all at all no no well I'm very happy
that you're on shameless shameless air
Sunday nights at 9:00 on Showtime Sasha
thank you so much for being here
[Applause]
you